haha and we are live Happy New Year
welcome to season two of the iron Lords
podcast episode number 45 it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day we've got a
very special guest ps5 vs. xbox two
potential Xbox exclusive leaks Nintendo
switch to cope digital energy drama and
possibly our 2018 outlook for each
platform to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce a Lord
whose meteoric rise on YouTube in such a
short period of time
it's nothing for anyone to be salty
about this Lord currently provides high
quality content thought provoking
questions to the community and although
his channel may be deemed Xbox centric
he's always willing to engage in healthy
and intellectual debate to make his
points known introducing the host of the
saltiest podcast and co-host of both X
power and loot chest radio the Lord one
of the best intro beats on his youtube
channel a devoted gamer and reminds
everyone to stay salty my friends making
his debut in the realm of the Lords
Marvin Lord salty is gaming how are you
doing sir wow what an intro I mean
goodness
hahaha red card is rolled you are in the
wrong I might record that and keep bunch
of really absolute pleasure to have how
you doing this I'm doing good dude I'm a
little tired cuz I was up you know
rocking pub G with the friends you know
I got some coffee and I'm ready to roll
man I'm diggin 2018 I think it's gonna
be a big year for gaming I love the
community and I'm just excited to be on
here guys I love your your content I
love what you guys do
much appreciated man it's absolute
pleasure to have you like I'm following
your journey and seeing you doing it
thing out
so you had to get the salty one no yes
Jose we glass foot so of course my
co-host with the coat most he's starting
his new work schedule he will be joining
us in progress but of course we got the
most technical game in Lord the recent
birthday boy in the solo player selfish
experience his switch online profile was
very heavy this week how are we doing
sir doing great man fantastic happy new
you everybody I hope everybody had a
happy and healthy in school too late for
the mix now in a business now everyone
enjoying yourself we're good doing good
I got to hang out with the Lord's
yesterday kognito and katsu a shout out
to Lord Maloney is for you son birthday
treat every aging feast my god dude oh
oh the XS gamer oh the Lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
and demands nothing less than that
premium experience Oh beloved Lord King
how are we doing sir oh listen guys I
know there are the boxes stuffed and the
UFC stuff I'm just gonna bring one thing
in this year then you know we're gonna
start off fresh next week Cris cyborg
men you should they should have the
crossover fights where you fight your
Jose Aldo these dude because I really
think you could take boy she hit him
with the with those punches that make
people you know defecate upon they self
in it I mean the woman is strong like
unbelievable
unbelievable she's an unbelievable
athlete she's like a once-in-a-lifetime
type of generation type of athlete she's
got oh I love to watch I'll fight all
the time beautiful um miss you guys
I was chomping at the bit I was going
crazy now round table this is home feels
good to be back and lot kings in the
building no no box well you know we have
boxing that's coming up you know we have
boxing that happened we have a little a
whole bunch of box and talk that we want
to get into oh but you know listen UFC
left a great impression upon me Cris
cyborg did what she had to do it was
nothing in boxing that looked anything
remotely like that Dana did such a great
job
I don't hardly home husband you're like
push the envelope I thought it was gonna
look fantastic no no it look like a
slaughter of course it is Lord Cognito
here spending the gaming realness on the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need here feels good
to be back like what Kings say so uh
before we get into what the Lord's are
playing don't want to get into a lord
salt this video game system history the
creation of the saltiest gaming youtube
channel x power and of course time
coming together with uh some good Lords
of mine Lord brap called a digital
Fonzarelli then they creating that Luke
chess radio so let's start from the very
beginning Lord so let's start with the
video game history
what's your first systems what got you
in the game uh okay so I'm pretty old
I'm in my 30s right so I went over to my
grandpa's and he had an Atari and I
turned that thing on that beast on and I
was rocking the pong you know with my
grandma back in the day that's when that
itch started you know
Gaming so then I went from there to you
know Nintendo and then Super Nintendo 64
so I was a Nintendo dude okay and you
know I went up from the 64 to the Xbox
original 360 you know the Xbox one side
you could see where it's going with that
one right you know so I've been in the
Xbox ecosystem I did I had a lot of
friends that playstation side go over
there and play their stuff so I've
dabbled in all realms but you know Xbox
has been the main place for me
majority of my gaming but uh yeah so
gaming I just it's been part of my life
my whole life nice nice now what else
get to your beginning in Xbox don't you
you had the the OG xbox as well the Duke
oh yeah Shola not so some games you'll
rock it out on those I remember going
into Best Buy
to get that and Halo was crazy man I
loved playing Halo on there and it was
just it was mind-blowing what you know
what that game was back in the day you
know if you think about it it was doing
things that we've never seen you know
absolutely so I like smart yeah you
throw like in you know they'd scurry out
the way the literally blew my mind is
when you turn the flashlight on it was
on the black camera buttons then you
turn the light on on the top of your gun
[Music]
yeah now I would you know Knights of the
Old Republic all that good stuff so that
the original Xbox says you know a
special place in my heart it was just
you know it wasn't the top dog at the
time but if you know they were coming
out with something new I don't know why
I picked Xbox but I think it probably
was the halo situation because I saw
that of my I love sci-fi I am a big Star
Wars dude so nice so yeah and I was only
later on in this segment
why you picked Xbox is like what we know
about that halo bell so then you
transition to the 360 pretty much
immediately Wednesday was they brought
that bad boy out
oh yeah I'm big FBS guy so you know Xbox
360 you know was where it's at I love
gaming with the homies and that's pretty
much why I've been in the ecosystem as
long as I have because you know Xbox
Live the originator you know we go
through that and 360 was just it was it
was the place to be back in that you
know that's like yeah it almost felt
like an extension because it was like
the Xbox the og like you saw the
innovation he saw like you know the hard
drive inside the Ethernet port
you know these things we talked about
far the markets off innovating as far as
from a hardware perspective and then the
360 seemed like that perfect marriage
and not even getting everything together
and with the games on top of it so it's
create whoo now did that 360 red ring or
you were safe god I was a big Cod - back
in the day so then I got transition to
battlefield and some other things but I
got the day one Xbox one I stood out in
the rain at Best Buy you know five
hundred dollar system with the Kinect
and all that loot that minion with his
day one controller and now I have the X
so that's nice I see DJ now quick
question so I know you said you started
off Kiley Nintendo land where did you
fade off from Nintendo and then the
other question I have for you is um
never any Sony systems like you never
like all your friends kind of had like
what was doing yeah see so the 64 I love
that system right we were doing I'd back
in the day we do sleepovers and do like
you know Goldeneye and no my car racing
and Maricar like Mario 64 was
arguably one of my favorite games of all
time lovin it okay yeah I don't know I I
feel like maybe I just grew out of it I
don't know I you know wanted to get more
I don't know more change right but with
the PlayStation like I said I had a lot
of friends that had them so I feel like
I was balancing it out by getting an
Xbox we could you know get the best
because usually an Xbox do usually comes
from on of Sega I don't know man I I
guess I was uh I actually didn't really
mess a Sega at all either weird like
hearing it because I'm hearing a lot of
people saying it like as far as like you
say two thirty year olds to like 25 year
olds some of them didn't have a Sega
system but our Xbox had I think a lot of
that has to do is PlayStation 2 was so
dominant back then and yeah yeah a lot
of them may not have had Dreamcast if
you're still in your like mid-30s you
may not have had a Dreamcast like I
played those consoles but I never owned
one because the ps2 was so dominant and
everyone had one oh good point
welcome Lord addict into the building
code that's a cool cool of video games
history got going on so then I want to
talk about like the creation of the
other channel like what got you into the
YouTube game to create that saltiest
game uh I've actually told the story
before but it's interesting my wife
actually so I have a daughter that's
four she's almost five she's autistic
and my wife wanted to create a channel
for the adventures that they went on so
she called it Kenzie adventures so they
do things like you know do whatever they
do they bring a camera along record it
and she had a channel and she was like
man you should
need to get a channel going for gaming
because you talk about it all the time
you will watch these on yes and all this
other stuff mm-hmm
and I was like you know that sounds you
know I was just dragging my feet you
know no finally I just I did it you know
I scouted this channel god I don't know
I had a direction but I didn't know what
I was gonna do like most people and then
we had some you know we had a podcast it
was called dads of gaming podcasts funny
thing salty wasn't like let's all laugh
for the thought of what we first were
gonna do for a change we didn't do
nothing like that with our channel it's
kind of cringy to go back and listen to
my original stuff you know I started
doing the Xbox news because it was like
I started the channel in June and then
you know around the time
III was coming out and there's news of
the you know we're talking about the
Xbox Xbox one X and all this other stuff
there's huge amounts of news going on so
I started doing you know reaction videos
on news and then I started talking to
Jay Fonz in his comment section I got
the low Fonzarelli we got to get him
Motor Show loves guns it and then we
became friends and then he was like man
I love your content and then he talked
as I year and then I did debate on his
channel with Jay Bari I think you guys
had him on yes yes I caught that debate
- yeah so I was fresh I didn't know what
I was doing right and I was going
against you know a seasoned vet with Jay
Bari and anyway it was holding it takes
a dysfunctional do to the debate man I
stay away from them yeah talking about
debating at all that's just not my forte
especially with gaming debates is kind
of a lose-lose situation because you
know a lot of our active
yeah really people are really strong
with their beliefs when it comes to
gaming you know so if you give a really
good debate you'll still be in the eyes
of the people that you're debating
against so like if it's PlayStation vs
Xbox if I give a really good debate
PlayStation people are generally gonna
say I took that L right you know so most
objective and so yeah I don't you be
that's a good little I pretty much did
that and then it just from there I was
invited to we did the saltiest podcast
we started that off and then I was
invited to do X power then I was invited
to be a permanent member there and then
you know Fonz wanted to do loot chests
radio and so then we're doing that and
it's just been crazy man like I love
this community and the growth has been
crazy we hit you know 2,000 followers on
Twitter and you know we're we're just
skyrocketing with you know the the subs
on YouTube so it's just amazing it's
been an amazing experience absolutes to
see just to see your eyes man I've ever
seen your star and I'm just like look at
Lord salt go he's out here the real
quick own I want to talk to you about
just the whole science behind the Dave I
think it's hilarious from what so what
made you decide yo salties game that's
it that's what I'm rolling no no you
know what I I wanna have a a brief like
respect go to him for you some the dude
that used the salt gift debut the new
icon I had to hit a rabbi tweeted you so
I can't like give us the science shout
out shout out to Jay fonts for the the
the icon cuz he made that like I talked
to him and we collab about it and he you
know that was his inspiration there so
yeah that's his work he's a very
artistic guy he's very talented he's
he's very humble so he's not gonna take
a lot of props but he deserves all the
props he can get right but salty is
gaming I can't tell you like I said I'm
in the the first-person shooter
like I love shooters and every time I
place shooters with the homies I get
salty as hell like they're just like
you're the saltiest guy I've ever met
when you play games and I'm like dude I
I just it is what it is right and when I
was thinking about the channel I'm like
everybody saying I'm salty so I wanted
to be like the saltiest gamer but that
wasn't available right so saltiest
gaming was available on all fronts and
you know when you're branding your stuff
you want it to be across all all
everything right Twitter YouTube Xbox
everything needs to stay the same so
people know what you are so that's where
saltiest gaming came out before people
knew what who I was there like welcome
saltiest gamer and they would just keep
saying that I'm like okay but yeah like
the stay salty thing came from like the
front what beer it is where he's like
stay something like what is it go sexy
what did you say like stays like so I
think I'm like that and I was like what
say stay soft there's stay salty my
friends and I just say that now and it's
it's caught on and it is stick yeah nice
nice that's good to see the journey and
like what you're doing out here and one
last question I have for you was uh
we've been doing this all the guest
recently I need lost salt get top 5
gaming franchises of all time man no
particular order no pressure
gaming franchises even if it's just the
game itself I know how go dimension halo
in this I'm assuming halo there
Mario okay definitely there let's see
I'm kind of particular to do man because
of where it like the roots there so what
else what else
The Witcher the wishers The Witcher is
up there for me and then what let's see
I'm thinking man I would have to put
Zelda in there just because I love the
way that game is so nice
okay okay nice that's that's a good
that's some good franchises me I'm
liking what you got all right thanks
long that's what's up
no doubt so we're gonna get into what
the Lord's are playing this week let's
start back off with our guest loss saw
so what have you been playing
particularly uh this week like what
games have you been touching uh I've
been like I said rocking out on pub G
it's just when you play that with
friends it's just it's crazy the stuff
that happens nothing happens the same so
you could get run over a car by a car
you know and we're just we're just
clowning you know native in the pet and
punk sit there we're just it's just
we're making jokes and it's just fun
so been rocking out a pub G the Devil
May Cry band picking I played the
remaster or whatever it's like the new
one that they made I do this yeah
through game pass and then the Devil May
Cry 4 I just started that I just been
bounced and back and forward I have
Assassin's Creed origins to finish so
I've been working on that and The
Witcher surprisingly I've been working
on that as well so that's what I've been
playing nice that's what's up my
co-hosts with the coal Moses in the
building so let's get him going what
you've been playing this week uh
actually I've been playing a lot of mana
I'm sorry I'm kinda under the weather as
well did room I'm playing life is
strange love the first one I play pub G
for like four hours yesterday big bad
John was playing shout out the Lord big
bad John he is hung he's actually really
be step up G he's loving it too he's
gonna do it he killed Cody's wood
yesterday what that wasn't the same guy
I have a screenshot it's like we were
fighting a team in front of them John
went into a house and then all I know is
just like oh man there's two people here
and he laid them both out and one of
them was coast east without flame we got
it we got an act coat I let go already
anchorman said something John said is
made with tubby
we got an inside joke the table
hilarious we're playing pub G shout out
the Lord sinister this is big bad John's
first time playing pub G right so we
jump it when you land out and you're
welcome blue oh we convince them to buy
that on the spot so he get there so
people start shootin off lucky
so then sinister tells on big bad John
hey get down
he's like going aback cool he's like
okay get in the tub he's doing this
stuff he scared him into dropping all of
his eye it was the baby him tell me
we're like yo you are stupid scared this
new flavor of G for the first time I'm
playing a lot of pub G I really have
yesterday man I ran over like three
people in a row they're like I was in a
vehicle and they're running and it was
one of the last circles that I just felt
so bad because there's nothing these
poor people could do they're in a big
open field and the only thing they could
really do is get ran over by these I'd
solve what have you been playing a lot
of switch I've been working a lot so a
lot of switch on the go
so I finally finished Mario and I went
back in and started keep trying to get
more and more moves and stuff like that
so that's an undertaking that'll be a
little by little thing so I think I got
back into a Sasson scream but I realized
this ass is Crede like it's such an
undertaking and I'm so I'm so like OCD
when I play that game is I want to get
to everything so I'm gonna put that on
the back burner and then I've been
focusing on Wolfenstein trying to finish
up Wolfenstein so maybe - I gotta hit
that - so trying to get through the
linear game first and then I'll get back
to AC origins
no Lord King what you've been up to
would you been playing oh man shout-out
to Chris Lord Chris Kelly Chris King um
shout-out to handle forgetting that
winner winner chicken dinner
I know it's very hard to do so we've
been doing it for a long time trying to
do it I've been playing arm pub G I've
been destiny so hard I've been destiny
all day every day it's so crazy nice
treats right now like is it got to the
point where this one dude had the
message me and said who are you um
who are you because I beat the boss by
my side I went through the whole board
by myself beat the boss and there was no
input by other two it was who are you i
burning graphics they're just gonna lead
it to my whole thing so you promote it
fill again has definitely done things
that has been unheard of in in the space
of a CEOs situation you know a lot of
CEOs get canned and terminated for stuff
that went on under their regime like
that and to stay firm in that and
streets like you know like the CEO team
captain that he is but he was crazy
right just let's just take it off this
punji thing right up she's crazy right
million in how many days they suppose
this was haven't announced what this
week about pub GT something they want to
brag about I talk about Xbox
it's probably fun his leg is up right
now because you got people playing I
look at my gamers list which is like no
no probably one destroy any plant Bungie
Hardman there I'm like whoa I haven't
seen this since halo everybody's playing
one game only time I see that happen is
the big picture play releases broken
game it's a broken game fundamentally
the game is broken but it's so much fun
and this dude had the foresight in
seeing this and saying this is a must
keep let's bring this over here shut up
the law salmon is like maybe four or
five million already man engagements
greater yeah it's it's it's it's sick so
yeah for me it's been on you know me
been still playing that switch a bit and
it's all about this is the police I'm
trying to finish it close to the end see
all the crazy tweets I've put out the
stuff I'm doing like that game the
writing is so amazing the things that
happens it's just so crazy I just got
rid of a serial killer that was
terrorizing the city Oh nuts
that gave us that s having so much fun
with it so I've been doing that I
actually got back into Wolfenstein as
well like like more solving them no king
I got like maybe two more levels done
I'm past the halfway point so I've been
trying to rock that you know destiny to
still been blazing all my solo time as
much as I can as far as the prophecies
getting those done those take long Loki
nothing I mean I try to respect this
space those intrusive gamers man you are
and I play with you like I'm intrusive
I'm sent out
with the join when you join me I'll just
get my little solo gave it off a little
bit that's why you won't you hit me with
the stop spamming me bro but um you
shadow first of all I got out my window
this week no cuz I shout out to uh those
big bad John anchorman and more sinister
getting me my first chicken dinner like
it was that one yo
and I literally killed no one
the next day John got a chicken winter
and single wow wow he's a beast man I
like the way he played he's a good shot
too Laura anchorman - I like the way
they they're very tactical
it's just they got a good coordination
and the rhythm to the way they do digs
you know I just tagged along I'm just
trying to stay alive that's why like mow
down like two or three squads by himself
he's a beast he's a beast for his first
time he's a beast man like I said shout
to anchorman Chavez said it's not like
the way they got good synergy as well so
um let's get into the poll results we
got our last week's losses especially
it's like it was last year last year's
i/o people results are in and the people
have spoken to the question with the
release of pop G on Xbox game preview
should consumers in general expect
higher quality from paying early access
games the winner at 54% in a very
intense three three way poll is the no
read the damn game preview disclaimer
before you buy so 50% nothing goes in
first and coming in at close second at
41% was the yes game preview is no
excuse for pub G group and of course our
shadows were in the building in third
place at 5% was the so one pub G 1
million 48 hours with more
participated in last year's vote so what
did the lost think about this I start
with a lord salt I guess what do you
think about the Oh game preview poll
drama huh it's interesting that you know
they were like read the print or
whatever it said it it's you know game
preview is what it is it's a it's a
medium for these developers to you know
perfect the game before it's full
release and I think that you know it's a
good thing and it could be a bad thing
right because it's a good thing because
we can you know get these games
potentially to or you know one or two
years early but at the same time
does it give these developers some some
room to be lazy I think there's some
potential there I mean they could take
their time if they're making that money
you know they could you know potentially
you know not get the game out at fool I
mean if you're making money you know
what's the incentive but I draw the line
where it's a really good thing and I'm
glad that Xbox and Phil Spencer and all
them decided to put game preview on the
system because even though these games
aren't finished you get to participate
in some of these you know really popular
games that you wouldn't be doing you
know we wouldn't be experiencing this at
this time you know blue hole came out
and said you know specifically if there
wasn't game preview and an Xbox it
didn't help them there's no way that pub
G is on consoles right now so absolutely
I think I think it's good it was I think
the stocks didn't even really like like
helping them is like an understatement
like they literally made them the poor
like Microsoft literally went over there
with their own their own engineering
team have made the port it's kind of
crazy isn't that somebody that's in
charge that does that you know what is
shout out to his team Mike Ibarra man
holding it down Aaron Greenberg the
squad is crazy man
this team is crazy his team is like
Jesus quad is like Halo team fishing
working King working hard for those fan
fest passes
I just really wouldn't you understand
what I'm talking about why in you don't
see why we gonna get to that point and
then you gonna be like damn and he
really loved this show so make sure you
guys stay tuned so we don't get into
these topics man we got a lot to discuss
so Lord King you are leading off there's
a power struggle going on in these
streets right for a long time we have
been driven by bits right 8-bit versus
8-bit 16-bit versus 16-bit you know
whose true 16-bit when they get that
system into the house we really find out
exactly what's going on under the hood
right and for a long time Nintendo vs.
Sega was the thing and you know 16-bit
in the big cartridges and it was pushing
us forward and Nintendo knew early on
this is will be very costly
um Sony gotten to the mix Sony it was
very intrusive they put they face into
the mix with the Sega and Nintendo and
they were like who are you and more
polygons in you that's one polygon
polygons it's a good try that polygon
game a new polygon really didn't look
right to shinden and he was like you
just don't look right don't stick to
your 2d brah the O's who so we had three
do we had people that was trying to get
in the mix and Sony physically forced
their way into our hearts physic to the
jet blast processing of dying continue
look he goes yeah
everybody was looking for that new hook
Nintendo knew early on after GameCube
all right we can't play this game no
more we can't play this disarms race no
more
so they technically move themselves to
the left right and they went to the side
and they were doing their own thing
we're gonna keep it about the controller
we because it was always about how you
interact with the video game itself
right and once sega hit this dead road
where they kept trying the arms race and
sony was just like so abusive to sega
they didn't see it coming and they got
you know first round KO KO beautiful
system um 3do was too pricey and we knew
they couldn't hold that um that that
stature so along comes this uh
Microsoft and they muddled a way through
they're not who we want them to be
they're not the the person that you
chose now you talk about dissociated
RACI time of the OG right they're not
the person that you wanted their rocky
to be honest with you to be honest
against all odds they're standing in the
mix and nobody really wants them there
because they want Sega there no that's
facts because shout out to a super
deformed game cast I believe they had a
shame is black Leon and um he he kind of
made it clear like he was saying that um
you know when Xbox gotten to get people
laugh that then like Microsoft's making
a second people didn't want you know
Marcus wife and I believe I forgot what
guess we had on I actually was ranch I
got the shut up the ran when he was
getting in the game and he actually
mentioned that you know he was a Sony do
it nanny heard that Microsoft was making
a system it was like I got like no you
associated them with Windows that yeah
that's a good point my can continue so
now we have a system that is looked at
as the the Sega wanna be you know like
but just doesn't have the IPS that we
want them to have you know like why
can't Microsoft get those IPS that
Nintendo has a sony has you know there's
always that question right why but what
Microsoft has been driven by its power
it's always been power it's always been
the power to perform if it had a hard
drive in a box that had an Ethernet port
in the back it always been showing it
look we can be here we different we have
ideas too we can bring stuff to the
forefront too so those people that you
know didn't like Nintendo or that was
Sega heads or didn't like Sony they went
over to Microsoft and they found the
home and first-person shooters and teams
and groups and stuff right so we've
always been pushing this this envelope
with Sony back and forth power power
power so this generation that came out
the higher-ups if Microsoft thought it
was a good idea to stick a Kinect in a
box and to put us under power for the
system that was coming out the same
shout out to the gun all right um that
was a fundamental flaw are we gonna go
to television mm-hmm remember it was
took up so much of it all the other
foolishness media said ended off he told
you if you can't afford our system we
got a system for you the ultimate
disrespect if you were to be online if
you don't want to be like we got our own
system for you we got for you
so essentially he I don't know in his
head he thought there you know he was
the bee's knees he was it it was topping
brothers they don't want you they never
wanted you they want Sega you after he
said that like I don't even know how Don
Mattrick found a job after that I don't
even know how he found a job going into
that like that must be the worst PR ever
hurt I've ever seen it I don't have a
somebody do that
but they sing behind them sabotage them
and I'm talking about like like people
who like industries that murder that
people get murdered come up with better
PR than that like it's like that is
legitly
the worst PR I ever heard from any
industry so tell you consumers to not
buy the new stuff to go buy the old
stuff what I remember look at this right
you have two systems essentially that's
pretty much the same systems and
fundamentally there was choices that was
made in a higher-up situation that
allowed one system to be perceived as
way more powerful correct right and um
at a point in time when Microsoft had be
multiple at C when you have multiplayer
and you have the DLC launching on your
systems first you can hide a weak lineup
you can hide inside your weak lineup
when you no longer own those cards you
cannot hide that weak lineup everybody's
yelling where's the game's Microsoft
where are your games but these are the
same three games you can put it out
every year but where are your games
Microsoft mm-hmm
you're not Sega so people are begging
right now for Dreamcast to this is this
is to let you know they're dying for
Microsoft to be replaced all right
they're dying for it if a sega system
came out right now with the same specs
as xbox 1x right now that will be held
as the second coming they gotta get off
the ground but to say that is not one
that they're not wanted and we're
fighting to be heard and we have a
leader in position now making smart
moves now soon as this X drop you heard
PlayStation 5 whoa I thought you had
your pro the girl was doing it what
happened no no no digital file Jesus is
explaining it exposed and showed that
their checkerboard rendering is not real
um 30 frames per second dropping down to
27 frames per second it's not real
if you want a board system go buy a
checkerboard television because you're
full 4k is not being used but we have a
system for you it's called the Xbox one
X all right so what Phil did was he took
away the merit of a power right
all right so Sony said ho-oh bi get that
bad we got to take that back
PlayStation 5 will be coming out soon so
if you were like yeah again what happens
to that X when I come out well that's
reasonably Microsoft has let it be known
that can work through an Xbox - yeah we
got it we got a shoutout a Dreamcast guy
actually we've had him on the show and
it's people so uh pretty much he's got a
friend and inside it at some you know
contrived inside a Microsoft that uh
pretty much the new Xbox is pretty much
ready supposed to be for 2019 this is
this is what the inside source is saying
and that you know how C we're gonna take
it with a massive game no pun intended
but um yeah so I mean basically to log
kings point it's like we want to bring
it to the table like you know one you
know how do we feel about these rumors
do we believe it on to you know does it
fall in line you know I mean if you know
Microsoft with an immediate counter to a
potential ps5 so looking at your topic
well whoever else wants to jump in you
know me this is some juicy stuff so a
lot of salt like I know you did a video
on this floor so like what do you feel
about this hey I didn't know who drink
the Dreamcast guy was so apologize I
kind of I didn't know like first of all
there's a lot of people out there that
claim to have sources in this industry
that don't he very well could've but I
did the reaction video based off of the
the guy that was writing the article so
basically in media in general or in
gaming media we just have to be you know
we have to do our research before we
start you know believing things because
it's very easy for people to throw up
stuff on the internet and claim that
it's true and then the masses run with
it on social media you know and then it
just blows up right but if you're
looking at it we know that in the
console space that the R&D on these
consoles takes years right
so Phil Spencer's already said that
there they're working on the next
console right backs they said Oh next
reveal - yeah remember that doing early
stuff yes so the timeline
it just got stew it has to fit into
whatever mold that they want for it to
fit in I personally think 2019 s too
soon but maybe 2 to 20 you know 2020 21
I just I think that they they want to
keep the power narrative but I also
think that PlayStation has a
money-printing machine in the
PlayStation 4 you know so pretty much
they're they're gonna be hitting a
hundred million consoles within what a
year a year and a half so they're not
really rushed to get a new system out
there you know like what is the
motivation for PlayStation to get a new
system out is my question they have the
the anniversary coming up and I think
2020 and people have been speculating on
that but the only motivation I could see
place they shouldn't even remotely want
to do that is if like Microsoft legitly
was doing that because they'd had to
respond like they couldn't go a whole
year and not respond they could you know
this is it brings some interesting
discussions at home it's it's
interesting she said that because I'm of
the same mindset no sort of like I think
it it may be a little too early but then
again you know to jump in outshout the
library had a good or rant recently and
um you know what they remind me of Lord
King it reminds me when 360 came out
because if you look at the history right
when the OG xbox let's be honest like it
came out that was them getting their
foot in the game right but ultimately
they knew they weren't gonna win that
gen that Jim was a L 360 what Peter
Moore was very south of Los Angeles he
what are you saying it was very
aggressive in making sure that they had
a year to market head start unless let's
be real like for all intents and
purposes this generation is over as far
as sales is concerned they're not you're
not gonna catch so maybe I even though
2019 may sound too early but maybe maybe
they said they'd say you know what let's
get this thing to market will be out
first we'll have the market share you
don't mean and then try to attack them
that way just to get a head start what
are the Lord's think about that I don't
think this coming out before the five
though okay so you feel it's wrong it's
gonna come out on around the same time I
think we're gonna get that do-over I
think we're gonna get that round-robin I
think we'll get that one more time let's
do it again with with the real dude in
charge of the ship you know we come out
a week to week or day to date or
whatever you want to call it but you're
gonna have his guns ready he's not gonna
allow him to take the power narrative I
can say now that I honestly believe that
the xbox two will be more powerful than
the PlayStation 5 they were not allowed
them to have any type of edge in any
area only exit sunny will have is
whatever stock of games that they have
from the PlayStation 4 that they will
rien Hance and bring them up to from
checkerboard to real 4k mmm no solve I
need you in on this wait what do you
think 2019 doesn't feel too early if
they're gonna continue this iterative
console thing if they're gonna continue
that in two years from now yet it's fine
they're gonna tell they can it's gonna
be a souped up rise in five or whatever
rise in seven console is gonna be able
to play all your older games and if they
continue this then 2019 makes sense if
there's if Xbox one X is the final Xbox
one and they're just jumping completely
then I would say yet is too early I mean
um
it because the thing is they've been
they've been focusing so much on this
ecosystem and trying to unify the
ecosystem to then break it you I would
think you just you need to give more
people time with their new console
before you tell them they have to break
it completely unless you're telling them
everything moves forward again I don't
know what play they were PlayStation in
this regard is that I don't know where
their mind is they might it makes sense
to me the only obvious way to move
forward is to continue with this
iterative stuff it just keep making more
powerful consoles right not people off
from their games but now they might just
they might just not do that to be
contrarian to what Xbox is doing mmm
because there plenty of people that had
that narrative they say you know what
now
if you if you allow me to play my old
games on this system then system isn't
as powerful as it could be and they're
people that really buy it - that blows
our sovereign you know with the crowd
come arrogance and what an arrogance
comes mistakes we see time and again the
hubris always gets to you where this
Microsoft was Sony the hubris the Sigma
soft it like Sunnis is such a dominant
position right they kill in this
generation like I still don't see the
need I mean yes you know in a bubble
with easy but the extra box 1x you know
and they're completely winning all these
you know president Wars and all this
other stuff I get it you know I mean we
know a superior version of the game is
on the Xbox one X but it's also one of
them thing they still got the exclusive
train they got that going they've got a
huge bunch of titles that they still
haven't you know you released that we
expect to be 2018 2019 moving forward so
it's like do they really they don't need
him with the exclusives they don't and
that's the thing Microsoft Microsoft has
to up their exclusive game considerably
to put the pressure on their neck to say
listen regardless of what excuses of
what what exclusives we have we have to
start pushing the power narrative again
because they have enough to combat us or
they have you know they may not have as
much but they have enough to combat us
people if the games are goodness that's
another thing we have to think about
what Sony generally their first party
stuff is usually very well received
very rarely do they have a first party
game come out or second party a
published game something like that that
is not very well received
whereas Microsoft's on the past couple
of years have been sort of middling like
even even a top franchises the halo
fives the the Gears of War you know
their people had issues with these have
to be exemplary titles if they're not on
that same level then yeah I don't think
there'll be I don't think they'll feel
the need to really push the envelope in
terms of power alright is it gonna have
the game really real quick let me give
it to you attic I shout out the Lex
hazard in a chair he made a point he's
saying that he doesn't feel that um
Microsoft needs they can afford it I
don't think they can afford
ps5 coming out first I'ma be honest
IIIi I'm nervous Sonne trained a Sony
train like again coming out first day
yeah I feel they have to it like you
said like what kids I feel they have to
meet them day and day and do like a what
is it 2013 / 2014 all over ya or put the
line in the sand or will you jump out
your Lord addict jumping I want I want
your opinion on this by the way where
you at you know if people think the mid
generations the only reason I think if
they Microsoft might announce in 2019
like mmm I just don't know but here's
the thing like I do have if they have I
have a have a I'm I'm sick for a second
okay let me jump in real quick
so I was talking to dealer about this
situation in a breach at and we were
talking about the next big jump for
consoles is gonna be the frame rates I
think that you know we're talking about
rising and all this other stuff I don't
think the prices of the CPUs are gonna
be where you need them to be to have the
cost of the system be where you need it
to be you know the Xbox when X was
announced that $500 and people lost
their mind right on that announcement
they're like oh that's too much people
aren't gonna buy it you know but I
honestly think that the next big jump
since we're at 4k right now yeah it's
gonna be that 60 frame target for most
games which is C you know intensive but
that does a better CPU would we can't be
running with these Jaguars again King
that's the only but could to you mustn't
cut you off I'm sorry could be yes so
you look at I think Microsoft has done
they're thinking about things right
they're going forward so this backwards
compatibility thing all the way back to
the original Xbox wasn't by chance right
they want to cover their basis they want
to say we got you covered with all your
games from the beginning and you'll be
covered going forward so this mijin
refresh I think it was a one-off thing
for Microsoft because they were so far
behind with the power narrative that
they had to do something you know they
created this powerful system to get in
front of the power because it was such a
big deal but I don't see them doing
these mid gen refreshes in the future
that's just my opinion and they've been
they've been asked about the situation
because they're like well are you going
into a cell phone model you're gonna be
pumping out systems every two years and
they said no we're gonna be continuing
generations so I think this the mijin
refresh was just a one-off thing but I
think the X is powerful enough to
compete for a while well like I said the
next big thing is gonna be the CPU and
it's gonna be frames per second so it
all it's all depending on how how fast
they can get that price point to where
they need it so it's not it's not effect
like you're there you know Sony's gonna
push a console out I don't think they
push a console
unless they're hitting 60 frames on most
games you want my honest opinion go for
and I really think that this is
Microsoft's play right now I think they
realize that the ps4 is not going to
slow down and stell it's not going
anywhere in sales it's just gonna keep
going up what's the one way that you
slow down a generation of cells easy
your next one you start to push the
reset button so I think that Microsoft
might not necessarily be ready by 2018
let's be right here you can make the
next generation next year if you put
enough money behind it
I feel like they'd rather take the loss
at the start of the generation and
perhaps lose the whole generation in
terms of hardware sales they'd have to
redo it buy software sales and you know
any kind of promotions they would do but
what would they do one it would catch
Sony off-guard because if they had let's
be real here Sony they tried that
waiting a year thing you did
work out for them Microsoft announced
it's coming out in 2019 because you know
they they you know that their condition
can you know the consumers do so what
that's gonna make PlayStation has to
announce there's in 2019 ish and I think
they're gonna try to offset them and one
thing I think that's really gonna help
Microsoft next-gen is you could play
your you could play three generation
again and I know that's huge that and
Sony doesn't do backwards compatible
which you know Kay wall well that yeah
that's what I'm saying that's just a
given Sony to make me think that they
want backwards compatibility brought
dankey then when they brought Yankee
they'd let you know their listen you
could buy you could play PlayStation now
anywhere you want to get it we had a
system for you oh yeah sorry for before
combatable well without PS 5 that's what
he say like I said if they want to be
contrary to what Microsoft was doing
they made this be like no that's that's
weakening the system like they just
change the narrative around same thing
with the 4k when Microsoft said true 4k
they said dynamic 4k nobody knew what
that meant
well sovereign Sony will put it in the
box for the first couple of systems and
then the next month you realize that
your system don't play it normal like
the peers they have versions of the ps3
backwards compatible with the ps2
there's actually a loss or two because
in that wasn't that one they're lost
books yeah they're one of the Linux and
they took that away the original OS
allowed you to Linux on there and it had
the built in backwards it's like look
this is where I honestly think
Microsoft's doing
they want to you know as much as I hate
to say this next phrase it's to take the
stuff that King David has been saying
just bored analogy he'd be using with
Spencer you've been setting up this
chessboard and then he will flip the
board and for start the next generation
and and that it's like look we got we
got 360 games we got Xbox one games we
got Xbox one and we'll just xbox two
games we got our opening lineup we got
the entire back generation and the
generation before that and even the
generation before that and Sony's coming
out with maybe 30 or like 30 games
let's see with that problem I see with
that it's like what lure salt was saying
is that do you at what point is
releasing it too early gonna have you're
gonna put yourself in position when you
get that but whole system is gonna be
something that's significantly more
powerful than the X it's gonna cost you
$700 it's not there's one thing that I
feel like is making this more more
believable is when they were just
fighting this with the ps4 but I feel
like the moment the switch came into
play and they started losing Mario did
the switch of what as well I feel like
they started looking more at that but
this which is such a different animal it
doesn't matter it's still taking some
money or base I'm talking about the
conversation we used to have was okay
switch is on a different plane and we
have install base regardless if it's on
a different plane oh I've always argued
that the money the money's being fought
for on the same level right everyone's
fight for the same dollars one thing is
when you're comparing the power thing I
don't I don't not gonna stretch power
I'm saying generations no power at all
in that state you're saying that just
because the switch has been successful
as it has it's saying that the generate
it what the generation is defined as who
made it power to anything either
what I'm saying is that what you're
saying is that since the switch has it
been able to find its its market share
and being what it is it doesn't
necessarily like the idea of where the
generation starts and stops isn't as
important as it as it was before doing
it signal could do whatever Nintendo
wants to do and the top that's my topic
what Atticus saying is Nintendo is the
wild card made a catalyst for what's
about to happen what I do I think 2019
is too soon
damn sure at the end of the day it's
like look like I'm not even saying what
you know dream anything dream heard was
wrong
everything dream could I heard is
completely accurate right that's their
release window all right I love that
mindset attic I love that Minds me also
sorry we also have to take into account
that there's sometimes fake leaks that
are thrown out there by some of these
companies you know to try to generate
this this buzz to try to either a you
know see what the interest is or be kind
of throw the other company off because
it is a big you know chess match because
let's be honest let's say Sony does get
a system out there and it doesn't hit 60
frames on all you know all games and
then Xbox comes out with one a year
later it's lower price and it hit 60
frames on all all games almost all games
that's a huge problem then Sony's in the
predicament that the Xbox one was in do
you see how that goes
like if this is a generation thing this
is a next-gen console it's a huge deal
you know yeah actually it's just gonna
be this huge standoff to see who you
know and Sony is the people that should
you know bring the system out first
because the ex just came out right so it
should do right I don't know it's crazy
to see what's gonna happen like are they
gonna drop at the same time are they
gonna weigh you know no real quick
before we wrap up I'm gonna give it back
to King um what do we feel like I'm not
gonna put this besides um let's just say
that with the whole one-year coming out
they write a lot I've seen a lot of
arguments of people stating you know
that that could be a big mistake because
you don't look at what happened to the
360 from our hardware from it like for
me being a rush unless I go don't rush
the system like do you think that would
play a factor into it as tough as it is
definitely being rushed if it comes out
19 there's no doubt in my mind that that
won't be rushed mm-hmm anything we'll
get an announcement 19 to come out in 20
Lord King your topic let's wrap this
thing man was gonna go up I love what
the roundtable had to say and I love
what the chat is saying um anchor I
believe you're wrong
we're what I see it is just like a
locust it is a launch window that's a
launch window 2019 is a launch window
right now Microsoft is holding the power
car mm-hmm
so if you are multiply developer and
you're making a game well our games
gonna be a 4k X whatever on the X and
then we can checkerboard it down that
way on the throw wall and bring that
across over there boom you know because
it's not really up to snuff with the X X
has so much room up in here so the power
card is being playing over on this side
and once you get to the point where you
can start getting these deals back that
we lost with the call of duty and all
this other stuff that we get the DLC
first and this is the plate the place to
place first once that narrative starts
to switch and you're gonna start seeing
it switch in that manner where the games
of course you can say yes only has so
many systems out but remember I told you
this bro there game sales are not
equating hardware sales and something's
up with you telling you to say I'm just
saying you know
these DS you say these guys sell 10
million euros which sells 10 million it
sells five million Mario's that kind of
makes sense these other dudes got a
hundred million and can't sell a million
games I don't know the finest is coming
from your Lord a decree to jet this is
not a run she'd come for your big but
they got the cars they're holding the
cards now we're holding the power card
one neck I got understand what they
talking about what he said check it out
check out what he said understand the
power card is this they're telling Sony
by telling them yeah I was ready to go
mmm
what's up bro hmm so you think it's
position you think you think it's like
think I don't not like whatever y'all
gonna be ready like cuz you don't know
where to move like like like Lord addict
says and and like Lord sovereign says is
will it be backward compatible or should
it be backward compatible how should
they move I know they have these things
view on how they're gonna do it and Sony
has always shown me they do not care
about the consumer so people created to
get a system that's gonna launch with 13
games like Lord addict said oh it's no
it's fresh it's more powerful rich yes
it's that and you can play your old
PlayStation 4 games on PlayStation now
about buying them all over again
mm-hmm still we can play everything from
the jump and bam and is stronger so o is
that that's that's how I see it I don't
know you guys the debate is beautiful I
love the chat it looks fantastic
um but I'm so happy that we're back and
we had this conversation boom baby doubt
there's a going this is going if
everyone's a wrapped up on the power
struggle we gonna move on and Lord saw
Microsoft with some some leaks and this
and the sink man what's going on we
can't start the year off with are some
rumors and some leaks this is gonna
happen I like though oh yeah I'm happy
for you
yeah I'm very happy with very happy for
you
so yeah I mean people are really excited
to know what Microsoft has in the
pipeline for this year right we know we
have Co thieves coming we have crackdown
coming we know we have state of decay
maybe or e so beyond that we don't
really know what's coming and phil has
been clear about stating that he doesn't
want to talk about anything before he's
ready to talk about it before they know
they have an actual game that they're
confident is gonna come out um but you
know people always want to know what's
coming next so basically over on neogaf
and resetter a-- a guy who's been known
for leaking quality information
information has kind of been people been
able to rely on was able to still access
old like Xbox API SDKs which he figured
he wouldn't be able to do anymore and be
able to kind of figure out what they
have in the pipeline mm-hmm and what
they have in the pipeline is some
interesting stuff so he could have
talked directly about what he saw so he
kind of makes phrases and inferences
around it and kind of indicating to
people what it is that is coming down
the pipeline so first off um he mentions
that there might be a return to out
beyond very soon
or at least an announcement or adjourned
I'll be off very soon and from what I've
been able to gather and I'll have even
been able to gather around the internet
there's it's kind of pointing to a
particular developer working with this
game that maybe people would not expect
um people looking at perhaps playground
games are the ones that have been vetted
to take on fable for when we got almost
confirmation from Jeff Gordon on that
yeah it's all true yeah so they're
hopefully working on playground is
fantastic they've been working on for
the horizon for years but they've shown
that they are they are a very competent
team I'm excited to see what they do
with that kind of any other leaks lost I
just gotta ask Lord attic so I need Lord
attic like when you heard about fable
you're so passionate about the series
and now you hear playground what do you
fear what was going through your mind
with that one like good conversation
with the ten dog over on Twitter on
indie games and it's like look man like
he assured me he's like look he's like
the game's gonna look good because
they're engine now first off I don't
even know if like a racing engine can
make an open-world adventure games but
you know I don't know how that works so
you can't really quote me on it you got
a player export it get the engines of
great like hot like I don't know John
your game right right I said just so you
know I would think you could but maybe
they would have to reoptimize the engine
is as flexible as the Unreal Engine you
look on row engines like the most used
engine because it's flexible like that
and then a cry engine is them yeah
everything is available it can do stuff
like that I'm not in the studio
obviously Microsoft is not going to let
them make the game with only people that
know how to make you know of course you
know yeah of course we got to take away
confirmation that it's true well it was
it was confirmed they were recruiting
people for an open-world RPG before the
veteran from Lionhead went to that
studio continued loss table with the
rest of these uh
leaky leaks okay so the next thing is
perhaps a return to perfect dark oh and
maybe the indication that they could be
going third-person with it instead of
first-person mm-hmm I won't know how you
guys feel about that I'd be honest I've
let me start let not stop to get on that
he got a lot to say
well the cell phone oh my god first of
all what game how many people have you
guys seen on uh no I'm social yeah I'm
cool with that bet you guys there hello
how many how many people on social media
have you seen begging for a new perfect
dark first of all I don't know I you
don't see that the man will be out there
but guy so you know so the perfect dark
situation is the one that like makes me
kind of salty because I'm like please
God make this not be true that's not
true faith was probably not Street this
guy this guy made some predictions and I
think most of them are correct so like
know if it's 75 percent I hope you know
the perfect so I don't know man it's
just not an IP that I think that they
should be focusing on let's just put it
that way because it just I don't know
what they could do with it
make it stand out in the shooter area
you know like if they'd gone
third-person they can go Syphon Filter
type of a hitman type away with it
so but getting back to the other topic
about having these developers start you
know different projects and you know if
you look at guerrilla games like what
was there originally working on you know
it was cool zone yeah and that's a
shooter I mean they went into this open
world archive and they hit it out the
park you know yes we look nothing like
horizon got a lot of people like first
off like I played a little perfect dark
but like I didn't play like a whole lot
of it it was so long ago I can't really
remember like the game thoroughly
was that like a stealth shooter no it
was like it was like the golden eyes
last James Bond type of thing with a
female lead yes deny engine and the
mechanics and improved on it was one of
the it was one of the cartridges on the
n64 that uses a used a ram to run better
and yes ram car so it was just one of
those things where it's like it improved
upon the golden eye formula after people
had fallen off Goldeneye and when
Microsoft acquired rare mm-hmm take that
flak franchise and run with it blow it
up and then the first effort on the 360
was not woody and in it went dormant is
dormant for over ten years and let it
let it stay dormant right I think that
if they made that a third person they
need to have the people who make he has
enough name recognition so that if you
blow it up and it's brand new it's
nothing it's not first person it's third
person maybe they focus on stealth
action third um I don't know the saying
of her shooter their first-person
element exactly may not even the
first-person elements maybe you
eliminated completely no I mean no if
you make it something brand new and and
you know make it more mature maybe scare
to get away from someone like them the
more comedic elements of it it was a
little it had that rare kind of all rare
kind of comedy to it you know mean like
the banjo stuff was like it had that
tone to it maybe it could be something
but it's to me only if they do that with
it if you give me the same old I don't
think it's really I don't think we're
putting a lot of money into the same old
no no let's go on with the rest of these
leaks cuz we still got some more right
we got a what was it uh Age Empire yeah
so we cracked down I believe they're
they're trying to work on four player
co-op which would be fantastic to me
like if they really went to the back to
run ball would crack down and they want
to make this title shine on the X this
is the type of stuff that you you want
to be able to see the game being able to
do running at a great framerate looking
beautiful like so hopefully you this
game don't come out doing with the
multiplayer that they promised this game
might as well not even come out took the
limbo and put it to the bottom bar and
they can't raise it anymore yeah I want
a copy that will get that we got
exciting there was no wiggle room
anymore like the note they offered that
kind of multiplayer experience that's
the only thing people want now mmm yeah
yeah so we have that um we have an
indication that for the horizon for is
gonna be in Japan like pretty that's
very exciting justified as a lot of
different ecosystems that is coming
about that is like imagine like the
irony of that like it's in Japan where
their competitor is like Sony's
headquarters they're like is it gonna be
great out it's got a funny it is good I
see pandering that's all I see I just
I'm just imagining like the neon lights
of Tokyo Forza horizon for flashing up
and good enough I could see a lot of
Japanese market picking that up like
just for that way
I can't see it at all if they do if they
do Japan Justice which they do I mean
these guys they researched extensively
like I don't see the messing it up hey
they literally haven't missed a home run
like ship with Japanese letters and with
the whole box art with a Japanese map of
they don't care they don't want you over
there they want say goods are going to
Japan he said he talked to her dan
Greenwald extensively about it three
years ago so shout-out to de Calonne
that one you said Tim I love it I love
the backdrop in what you call it in
Japan I think that would be hot date
next week is it finally played a game
with 4k textures later
Vanessa no yeah I like what I'm seeing I
mean I think you know obviously this
guy's his history has been pretty good
for a mom this a club real I can't even
pronounce his name
it was always yeah like you know a lot
of stuff I mean we even said when
looking at the PC er conference and we
saw Age of Empires wasn't announced
they're so stupid you know I mean like
didn't announce this for them like the
PC show is an extension of the Microsoft
show me move shows together you had a
complete show right yeah absolutely 100%
agree so now it makes sense because
maybe from a Microsoft standpoint
they're saying you know what let's get
our keyboard and mouse support set up
right we can get that you seen the ball
moving on that so again a lot of these
weeks I don't want to give it say it's
the gospel but a lot of it you
theoretically it is sound it sounds like
it's making sense you know bring an Age
of Empires to the Xbox with keyboard and
mouse coming soon that is perfect sense
right so the last last two big leaks oh
yeah I'm sorry no no continue continue
imma let you finish off so the last two
big leaks well first of all there was
nothing substantial in terms of conquer
and your crimson skies for the
foreseeable future there's really
nothing that he saw that indicates any
homecoming school muff know that the
mecca salts so-so oh he said this is how
he rephrased he's like oh and I think
I'm sure Phil likes mix so there's
something the mecha-suit been coming I
don't know how soon now maybe just an
announcement um sent for Xbox because it
takes it takes the hardcore stuff from
MechWarrior and it Ming and it turns out
it's an action game that a lot of people
could get behind makers MechWarrior is a
little more hardcore like it doesn't
appeal to everybody make a Stoller
something it plays more like an action
game with crazy explosions crazy would
be fantastic Nintendo Nintendo locks
everybody up in the treehouse right so
nobody why there's no fear of Microsoft
yeah I gotta I gotta agree with a little
kick in it's like as much as I love this
type of stuff and it's great to talk
about him you bring it to the roundtable
I'm kind of low-key disgusted and it's
always Microsoft stuff getting leaked
that all about them like I'm really Emma
I mean I'd like to know what the party
is like don't you feel like the last
three threes we idea of what affinity is
gonna say before they present we had two
white people before he walked out on
stage we did but not last year at e3 we
didn't know anything about last like
like literally the games that we knew
we're gonna show up what it is that's
true that should show like when he
walked out was like we have 43 games I
was like cool man a lot of the gates I'm
thinking like I was expecting a favor by
the year that I was like didn't guess
none of us
my back my list was dead wrong what do
you feel about bikers over these leaks
in general man it's it's tough because
like you guys are saying it's like you
know what's gonna happen before III so
that kind of like skews the results I
think for you know when they give the
grades afterwards I like oh you know
this person what this team one or this
you know this company was like well if
you already know it's kind of it takes
away from the excitement and like the
the shock factor not getting the job
namely what gets people that W so
excited right like when you use
something that you never anticipated and
you come out like wow I didn't see that
coming but it's like it's like looking
says like it's almost having like a
little cheat sheet in the white paper
like okay he should be walking into a
movie in knowing I mean you know a lot
of this stuff it feels it feels very
true you know loss office your topic
what do you feel on your own town so so
just really quickly that the last leak
that they mentioned so apparently he
indicated he hinted that halo might have
some sort of massively multiplayer so
maybe something in the battle royale
vein for halo coming I don't know talked
about this I'm putting this out there
please do not put that as no little mold
on top of my halo stick I don't work
that I don't want to move I don't want
to surf I don't want know that if you
wanna do the game you make the game the
halo o TST to where you can drop your
little
Marines into the field and they can go
Greg guy this stuff and have it as a
combat trainer I don't care how you do
it make it its own standalone real game
with real shooter mechanics because
that's the pride of a pub gene the
shooter mechanics is off put real shoot
Kennex into this thing here in the Halo
universe I don't care how you do it but
do not add a mode to my halo by you
putting in a mode don't waste your damn
time because I will not purchase this
game
what a stupid motive you don't know you
know what you put your chicken did is no
no separate out of my goddamn game make
sure this game plays well alright we had
a problem with narrative we didn't have
a problem with modes we have enough
modes in G mode inside my game like big
let's go say alright we know this battle
royal crazy you know we got fortnight in
there look so you don't want no pause
you know no make a game make a game you
made a strategy game for the Halo Wars
right okay give them some respect and
you have ot st have his own little pub G
type of game where is a little Jean
right thing over there do not do that I
swear do not do that you know me you
gonna have that conversation I hold your
hand I'll be fun and we're saying now
put that damn move in that game it will
see where Lord addict what do you feel
style boat for a halo if I have to agree
make it its own game its own game you
know hundred royale where you know thank
you you spawn like the majority of them
are ODST and it picks rain to people to
be smart easy so yeah I will say this
look let's see weird to put that demoted
or if by the time we get to this about a
low six maybe they can handle like a
hundred versus 100 where you have a 100
Covenant of soldiers versus a hundred
but yeah some truth though because
didn't
Halo 5 what is it we didn't have war
zone with
ting would like beep with that yeah yeah
that was fun yeah that don't don't
expand on what you made already stop
jumping
trying to be a jack-of-all-trades you a
master of nothing Louis am i he said he
didn't say battle Roy specifically it's
likely it was one cool point on that
that mate that makes me a lot of sense I
agree with Louis am loss or loss so
let's finish this thing up what you got
feel okay basically I think I'm a mambo
I'm on board with you guys with the
Battle Royale situation I talked about
in my video I just don't think it makes
sense the multiplayer is doing very well
over there with Halo 5 so if it is if
they are gonna do something like this
make it stand alone but I would like to
see like you guys said with the warzone
I want to see them make that bigger and
like crazier you know I'm saying like
maybe a mode where there's more vehicles
more people I think that they can expand
upon that and make that crazy because
you know we have the Xbox one X and the
power of that system so you know on the
e3 stage you know I I guarantee you
they're gonna be coming out with that
that halo announcement and they show the
power X you know who the sky's the limit
you know but I don't the pub G thing the
Battle Royale thing I just don't see how
it works in the Halo universe you know
it doesn't it doesn't feel right it like
it's like you're trying to jam a square
peg into a round hole it just doesn't
yeah Llosa I definitely agree I think I
think it's warzone 2.0 and I think just
they're gonna utilize the power the of
the extra really show you know you can
have a hundred people running around and
like like you said like more what more
vehicles weapons like aerial combat
ground combat like they just want it to
be a true war zone and feel like it like
anything very clear very chaotic all of
it yeah he's saying maybe 20 versus 20
I'll be kind of late yeah I'd be crazy
so it has all the bill at cost because
they did say the league said work on
consistent connections right so yeah
so I hope it's something like that I
don't want them doing some me to thing
they just expand on what they've been
doing warning it and everything then
you'll start having forza having problem
or do this I don't want anybody else
doing pub G the less than doing it
better than pub G okay I just you know
so overall I say I agree about the leaks
that it's always Microsoft leaks that
are coming out but I think for for where
the fan bases they like to know these
things to have an idea that Microsoft is
listening to them and their stuff coming
now my only question is how close is
this how confident are they and even
talk mentioning the stuff and announcing
it this year um because this is again
this is information has been gleaned so
it's no guarantee it there's an
announcement coming this year so we may
be expecting all this stuff and then be
disappointed we don't hear about it
because it's it's not far enough along
so who knows like I just like to know
that that they were working on stuff
that we've been asking for and you know
hopefully some of this stuff is closer
than we think it is yeah great topic
Lord solve that was real fun I mean
leaks are interesting but at the same
time is like you know what if not by
boat I don't want no leaks in my book
look kick it out about these leagues I
feel you know somebody gotta shut up
they gotta catch them making an example
of like and how did that matter to me
anyway but he needs to be captured and
tortured and made an example because
somebody lost the finger where Sony know
morally they know that you got to do the
Harry Caray over there so they know for
sure we're not leaking at all come on
man somebody beat up leaks in with
everyone's doing we gonna move on I want
to talk about my topic next I want to
talk about the US Gulf the did tell dope
you have been riding this horse I just
didn't want them to rob you from
November technically 1 November it would
be funny it would be funny if they came
back in 1 December so back with these
high sales broke know the us as far as
the fastest-selling console it so as far
as 2 days as far as 10 months it expects
this is it basically shattered the we
are like the we I me remember when the
we dropped in and how in creative hard
it was to get it was like you know
Tickle Me Elmo status for a toy trying
to go please do not look at that comment
section right now - at least 5 times
over the switch he gotta be in that
little I gotta give us
to Las Vegas because my Twitter direct
has been blowing up every other day with
which news a hero just put out the other
day oh you know that's Longinus which I
say yeah yeah yeah we got that a four
case shut up to be money I seen you we
was on the frontlines baby telling me
God God without the song all the Switch
gay got did a little Kofi all of God but
um what I thought was interesting too
besides that obviously you know that the
u.s. sales but also in Japan like
basically the media crazy sales they
just came out and check this out this
blew my mind it managed to surpass the
first year sales of the ps2 in Japan
that's in C so basically I think it was
like 123 million for Japan during its
lifetime but I believe the ps2 also
where the parent was so great that the
ps2 also launched in March back in that
day and I believe they sold over about
three million units in its first year
and the switch to pass it with like
three million two hundred fifty eight
thousand units sold through 2017 so with
all the success you know do we see this
train stop and what do we feel you know
and obviously know there's a Nintendo
Direct coming you know it's supposed to
announce this big league corner on
Amazon they had like placeholder for
about 20 plus games you know this is a
huge year for Nintendo as far as the
momentum can they keep this up so I want
to bring this to the Lords now let's get
it let's get to more so because I'm lost
I don't I don't believe you don't have a
switch correct you're not you don't have
to switch game no I don't
so the the Nintendo system is like it's
in a perfect situation right it's a
hybrid console it's not really a console
it's not really it's like more of a
handheld I've stated that and I get
blasted for that I just you know I see
it as a handheld and it's it is catching
these numbers for consoles and it's
being you know touted as a console so
it's hitting these numbers as a console
the price points perfect it's $300 it's
a compliment system so everybody it's
not you know it's not so much it's like
oh playstation or xbox it's like well
all the PlayStation dudes
and all the Xbox dudes they buy this
system as a compliment you know it's a
compliment they play it on the go you
know it's not it's just there in a
win-win situation that's why it's
exploding the way it is
because we've never seen something like
this Nintendo took a gamble we you know
the original Wii was a it was innovative
and it sold like hotcakes and this is
the same exact thing for this system
because it's a compliment man just like
you guys were saying you know you can
take it to work you can play it on your
break you can you know it's it's just
portable it's it's it's it's affordable
and I don't see it slowing down honestly
like I think it's going to continue its
upward trend and you know the market
more moving forward you're gonna see a
lot more you know multipe lat you know
these businesses are gonna want to come
in and support this system because it's
selling more so it's just it's kind of a
ball rolling down the hill I do have
issues with the fact that they got this
system out and they don't have basic
themes I mean you got to rig it up like
you're you're telephoning with a can
with a just sell the switch of a PSN
card or an Xbox I you know Nintendo and
Xbox are pretty friendly I know they're
doing cross play with Minecraft hell
just you know ask them for some you can
you must give Phil a gold storm in that
relationship so you can't underestimate
that man like that cross flavor
minecraft is very special
especially if they continue to hear get
a lot of flack over it too because like
Nintendo are trying to keep up with this
perception that people want to switch to
have and I just don't think Nintendo got
the software engineers to do it don't
you think that in Phil's DMC shooting
the dam at the head of we don't just put
it in every every time they announce
something that people will like come on
Nintendo you doing so good Phil right in
that DM I can fix that give you the
floor hear me we were riding that train
so it's good to see you don't say we out
here doing the Lord's work
we just forced myself to work for four
hours this is not shameless plug try to
get some you some XDM that one actually
has been helping me out because you know
I've been having to make it to work
every night and you know check on these
guys and do this stuff and if it wasn't
for that DM and I swear I would not
making it so you feel bad a lot and get
some rest man bro you got you back this
blue has got you agreeing with me
adding back you better bro Lord so back
to the floor to you as far as our our
our celebration happened so I have to
say like I was on my feelings a little
hurt
I'm telling you something every month
right after that right right I remember
way back early in the year before the
switch launched we had low carillon in
Lord cows the next box mafia family
podcast yeah what me and Lord solve
I got jumping lo saw I was like they're
not gonna be a factor Noah's gonna tick
bones but be it saw was right everybody
look it up you go to IOT archives I
believe was the ILP III prediction so
Microsoft we had Lord cow we had Lord
Tim dog on the show
hey we were calling it then so back even
when B money was called we was calling
it we were like yo mark so I better stop
playing around
cuz the tenons coming around the back
door my exact words but Nintendo is back
in the building you have to be wary of
their potential for making money like
they did they just where if they give
you a quality product they gonna make
money and they gonna make a lot and it
was just a matter of where the product
was gonna be quality or not and it's it
so to me it does it makes perfect sense
like
the numbers that they're showing in
Japan makes sense because Japan is very
portable centric now they would not have
they would not have fallen in line for a
true home console again yeah you would
not see these numbers if switch was not
a hybrid console I agree money be money
I don't hate the switch bro I love the
switch I have all the games for the
switch the power of Nintendo man when
Nintendo has a quality product they know
and they know how to make money off of
it Oh despite still making mistakes that
we look at like huh like you know like
despite probably not having as many
consoles in a while does it like despite
still not fixing their online issues um
despite still not fixing their storage
issues like there's still stuff with the
machine that makes you kind of scratch
your head state apologia systems what
what that portability that portability
it allows them to be in the conversation
without being in the conversation it's
completely it's nobody's looking at it
as oh this is a three tiered thing now
whereas before when they looked at it
and they have all had to compete on the
same level Nintendo could just not
compete anymore once after the Gamecube
it was obvious that the the the market
could not withstand three pure home
consoles it wasn't gonna happen because
Nintendo's first party output was never
gonna be enough to sustain a home
console on its own without true
third-party support so this this is
something I hope I hope they see this
and realize and realize that this should
be the way they operate moving forward I
don't want to
even the Nexus Samantha Smith is
literally I fear this is the form factor
I'm funny I'm glad you said that this is
the form factor they need iki
you you know it already to stop it
system with a circle controller is right
knock I've set it I'm not confident in
their ability to get out of their own
way and ncua the way for it is they've
always said they considered themselves
tinker's and women and toy makers before
anything else sometimes I make
creativity for no reason sometimes they
they want to make that uh their system
that failed that what was it the the the
3d system the the virtual boy they want
to make that a thing so soon you're
gonna be able to plug yourself into
Alexa guys they say the switch XL the
Chu for King handheld coming soon I will
say this I think we'll get a revision
yeah they may Nvidia so NVIDIA has all
the incentive in the world to say let's
Rio Tegra 2 more power please keep the
same form factor and they come salty I
got a question for you um being in you
know that you were on um I mean
everybody here you know be honest with
you do you think um this is just
throwing it out there do you think with
the GPUs knowing that Nvidia is 10 80s
and 1080 T eyes and everything like that
has one of the GPU wars in this
generation do you think to get an edge
and power Sony goals they're out just
throw that out there there's a question
I have
CPU itself that's it honestly I don't
know man
III think they might but like I said I
think the focus will be CPU on the next
system so they they might go that route
plus you know the upgrade to the horizon
you know so right yeah we all figured
that the Rison will be the next
iteration of the CPUs so everybody with
this switch upgrades you guys think it's
gonna be a straight upgrade to the you
know the tablet or are they gonna try to
update that dock system like where do
you see the upgrades coming in I think
the doctors long has to be smaller
because I they've already seen
third-party to be able to do it I don't
see why you're gonna give me another
bulky dock that I can't see the screen
and doesn't make any sense so hopefully
they've taken that into account and I
certainly hope something smaller more
portable and the machine is more
powerful and give me and use the fact
that that um the machine you have these
in you know the interchangeable we move
the stuff like that like if you don't
you can improve upon aspects of the
machine while still keeping the core of
the machine mmm so to me they got a
formula man they got they got the form
factor down beautiful tech
I think they can do the upgraded system
like the excel um and give you like that
little booster chip inside the back for
the booze for certain games like they've
been going with the 3ds you know like
you know that with this little arm if
you use army balls with the 3d X through
yes certain ones weren't able to use
amiibos so you had to get this reader
this an NFC reader separately so they
could have that you know like if you
don't have that upgraded system then you
can use this chipset inside of it or
whatever some long extra and just real
quick before you finish up a switch um
yeah we got a big January direct coming
so I'm just you know out it obviously I
miss on it leaked all these place hold
of these games you know what do we
expect and what do you think they need
to do to continue that momentum from
from the title standpoint like what do
you feel like let me go a lot King
because um I know you know you kind of
cool or them
I'm actually pretty excited with what
their lineup is going to be in the
coming of you know futures of the like
the f0 system it's not saying that you
know you can't do it or just put it on
our low spec PC but um just got to
refine it completely make yourself my
thing is you know they have enough IP to
keep me interested all the way through
they kept me very enthused this this
year with what arguably games of the
year for me that Mario was insane the
Zelda is insane I could have deal
without that little fake boxing crap
game that they put out that I want my
money back give us punch out this year
Oh could you imagine punch out like
really like you can swing off I mean
really good game Johnny what that GTA 5
tool I'm looking forward to their IPs
that you made a drop so yeah I'm pretty
sure they're gonna have a steady stream
of them you know the Kirby's the the the
the Yoshi's and stuff like that that's
gonna smash bros i will give my social
security number out for that lord saw
what would it take for you to pick up a
switch what do you need the party system
man is a huge drawback for me and then
the way you have to invite your friends
you have to give them a code social
security number those haha is that what
you try to say you guys heard that
they're not gonna be putting out a 64
gig game card until 2019
yeah that's a huge that's a huge thing
man
yeah so in order from the get doom on
the system they had to like split it
they had to do some magic like voodoo
work in the back corner or something
like that you know like half on you know
ship it in two parts the campaign was on
the game card and multiplayer is a
separate download I think that's gonna
be an issue because like they're getting
more third-party support but man man
that's a huge you know I I want to see
more third-party support but I think
they'll try to come up with this some
some you know resolutions for this but
they have one of the other things that I
have a gripe with is them coming out
with these mini systems you know like
the NES and the the Super Nintendo and
they're gonna be mowing or I love those
it would have been awesome for them to
have backwards compatibility with you
give me my damn Virtual Console please
have all the games there for you to be
able to play I mean you could pay for
them they can make money and it that
would be a huge thing for them to kind
of you know spread out and then get
people they are gonna get finally gonna
give us Virtual Console this year they
better do it fast because to be believed
people are gonna be able to put unsigned
code onto that system nice and that's
when it's really good so if you if you
think it that it is remotely its sold
now forget about it once it gets hacked
mmm no I think you said low so it's got
a good point because I think you know
for the hardcore like him like in order
for him to get I think like if you if
you hear announcement like of a
dedicated online proper infrastructure
with a dedicated friendless and real
chat and I think achievements that can
entice you I think that's what just
holding the hardcore back I mean once
they have those basic quality
life features grandpa I laughter is what
I got on the switch if anybody else
wants to jump in we're gonna move this
thing on and um actually this was a
late-breaking Oh digital foundry better
and these are famous Brits who are prone
to rip your resolution in your frame
rate if your game ain't up to snuff
apparently the game in question is games
called readout and apparently got an
Xbox 1x enhancement and you know did you
finally put a video up and pretty much
you know basically saying that it didn't
hit the target you know that it didn't
scale and um pretty much the CEO of read
out I cannot pronounce this gentleman's
name correctly but I'm gonna try its
Valerio DiDonato he basically came out
with a statement and he was just like
you know waking up to a storm raging
upon you he said basically what I can
call digital foundries technical
analysis at best is fake no she's gone
yeah he bought he busts his gun
early he said it might have been a
competent sort they might have been a
competent source of technical
information in the past but it's
currently going down the click baiting
half another shots fired at digital
foundry he said they'd publish an
opinionated video which they talked
about the Xbox one X version of our
readout saying that it um mentioned that
it just shows 1080p rendering he said
that is a straight lie he goes to break
down you know how it scales in
resolution between ninety percent and
fifty percent of 94 NATO 4k he goes
further into the technical details and
he's threatening legal action against
boundary now since then I believe it was
yesterday or this morning that when it
was maybe yesterday or digital foundry
kind of actually tweeted and they
actually said that there was an
oversight you know they actually are
they actually added at the other actual
death I believe the devs name companies
twenty four three four big things
and I'm just that they're going to be
correcting you know correcting this
information that was oversight I sort of
video yeah so the damage has been done
you know as far as the negative because
obviously the the dev was getting killed
on Twitter people were saying you guys
are lazy
how in the hell is the Xbox one X
version not optimized you know typical
you know lazy port I want soup I want
you to I want you to sue because what
I've been watching and I've been
noticing the narrative a tiny little pro
was trying to do this loose moving his
little shoulder lean you know say they
are the proud was doing it what's up
with the eggs oh what's going on I just
turned the channel because I says bogus
I know you lying
it was a good I mean I believe a lot of
people going at it is to see if um you
know if these guys three four big things
have the leak the litigation if they
have them standing table to sue these
guys so I wanna bring this to the Lord
first we do know you know the importance
of digital foundry and how you know
their reporting is very integral to a
title so now that this news is coming
out and we it seems to be incorrect you
know what do you feel about this looking
you have a lot to say so we we said hey
we you know because digital foundry
I tuned into digital fair because
digital foundry told the truth and we
said that we had to eat whole you know
did your fans who say you know it's true
it's true did you friends and you know
what I love I love the fact that Phil
went over to these dudes and he said
these dudes he put them on a pedestal
cuz he know he knew behind the lies they
lies we will put a target on sales
master plan he's he's the overseer
whoa-ho-ho the little hand is behind me
back a little more
cause the little puppets already seen
there and they got bigger fetch the bad
biscuits on the price I couldn't believe
I was disgusted to because I won so to
wake up in the tweet okay it was a twist
that I woke up to and it was the deals
from Laura Cognito LOCOG Mito blew my
phone he said it busted the corner I'm
so happy right now
day the developers say they feel so this
gives the lane to any up-and-coming
digital foundry type of company video
bloggers or whatever to come out with
their channel to show that listen we
have credibility here we can show you
running at the same to show that there's
nothing behind the gate we're holding
nothing back we're on bias to give you
another opinion instead of one
definitive place that you go to that has
to be the end-all be-all so this allows
the lane to open up for more people to
come in and to give you their opinions
or their facts no doubt no doubt
Lord saw I need your opinion on this and
ever since this news broke with digital
foundry possible lawsuit and read it
right out man I've seen people with
torches and they want blood on social
media being I don't know like okay I
don't know how digital founder you got
to this point we all know their rise
right they become the end-all be-all for
analysis on games and it's gotten to the
point where when the ex was coming out
they were looking at the X first and
that was kind of the the the the mode
for Xbox to get their their word out
almost you know people were like digital
foundries doing a better job than
in marketing then then ex-fiancé to show
the difference there because they didn't
want to do it themselves but the problem
that I have is there a YouTube channel
you know they want to make money it's
like they talked about how they're
turning into clickbait it's like yeah
they're click baiting people because
they want to make money so it when when
this happens and they get exposed for
making a mistake because it's not the
first time that they have made a mistake
they've had a you know retracts some
situations yes then people start
questioning your credibility as a source
and when that happens it's there's it's
it's a very sticky it's a tricky subject
for them because like once you see
analysis on thing so you're gonna
question it right you're gonna be like
is this true or is it fake because you
guys named up right so before this point
people went to them as the end-all
be-all source for Comino analyzing video
games and all that but I think after
this point people are gonna start
looking maybe for other sources or you
know question their credibility
altogether and that's bad for them you
know yeah we'll see man now let me let
me ask you made a good point loss sword
in reference to like in the clickbait
stuff and I always felt this in the back
of my mind I mean it goes down to wait
till we get to the poll later but it's
like it goes down to like what drives
traffic and and they have their finger
on the pulse of what's going on with the
console boys right they have their
finger on the pulse of what fanboys care
about people want to tune into that
video and see what version is running
better who has the better frame rate who
has the better resolution and that's a
point of contention and that drives
traffic so when you have that platform
you gotta be careful they like you you
get your eyes gotta be down your T's
gotta be crossed you know kind of like a
shout-out to a relevant native in a
controversy drives traffic I think and
they they they're guilty of that too
some respect we have to we have to put
that on them a little bit you know yeah
cuz let's let's be honest you know
PlayStation has the player base right
there are over 70 million the Xbox one X
is a more powerful system in every way
right so they I don't know if the
reviews are going down or
like because they're coming out with
these videos that people know what's
gonna happen it's like people going into
a movie like we said they know the
ending of the movie so why would they on
your video the exit we're powerful it's
like will surprise no one cares right so
it's like I think they're just kind of
fishing for that clickbait narrative
it's like oh [ __ ] we're gonna we're
catching the X and this this this is
this one game that it sucks that and
then it was no I don't know man
loss off job in we can't selectively
pick when when when we think digital
foundries not being objective and I mean
he's gonna be hitting at the start at
the start of the regeneration it was all
about it was it was a resolution gate
and place a circle around and they were
just telling the truth when he got the
hands on the X
they were very objective about saying
okay I gotta say this and I don't mean
to cut you off but then beginning a
generation they just put up two consoles
they put up the PlayStation and they put
up the regular Xbox and they knew that
the regular Xbox was coming in short but
then right what's the X started comp
once it was the X and it was the Pro
then all of a sudden the PC comes into
play who's this guy
no I but if I if you think about it it's
if you look at it if you're looking at a
1080 like I said like you know what a
1080 Ti versus an Xbox it's obvious
anybody who knows anything about it's
obvious is gonna be more powerful I'm
interested in seeing how close the Xbox
one X gets to it so I don't see it as a
negative when you put it up against the
PC because then you don't see it as a
negative I see it as another narrative
or pushing my brother back into the
corner no it's my brother's time to
shine them up against - dude that was
running his mouth before is these two
you know it's not it's not two fighters
in a referee fight I agree for that they
know full well how much they're eating
off of this they know that right at the
same time they are tech dudes who pride
themselves on their knowledge of this
stuff I don't think they purposely gonna
put stuff out there just to create beef
this is what they do I
within that they know they'd only had
clicks on it but I think within that
they want to put out stuff that they
believe in right they don't want to put
out stuff that's there are straight-up
lies and the probe that's it and if you
want to do the whole X versus the PC do
that segment we already know what's
wrong with it that's exactly but I'd
like to see how close that X comes to
the PC but let's just win give me my win
losses for so long watching this
stupid-ass channel for so long for the
next the next year at least or more or
two year we're gonna be seen and
Playstations taken elves we're gonna be
seeing that right this is and this is
the thing that pisses me off about this
the developer is kind of the thank you
Father really oh sorry
thank you for Fonzarelli want to donate
much appreciated yeah when the Lord jump
the gun like he went at them like with
the quick baby stuff that's it's kind of
ridiculous because at the same time they
they came right back and they said you
know what we got the info from VTech
it's if the resolution is scaling is
dynamic it goes from this range to this
range it doesn't stay stagnant NEP our
bad now afterwards the developer goes
and says yeah but the issues with the
with the framerate are true like in the
x1 X in in the patch for the Xbox one
edge there's still not hitting the 60
frames per second that they promised say
you can't pick and choose what part of
the argument you're gonna be pissed off
about like no are you pissed off about
is head up right do the head up well you
want to do head up with the PC versus
Xbox fine do that if I want to choose to
look at that
no I want my win give me my way off for
this is dead I'm not talking about you
know I'm not gonna pick and choose I've
talked about the developer picking and
choosing what part of the argument he's
pissed off
listen listen if they misrepresented you
in any form of fashion then you have a
grounds to state your opinion write your
opinion all the fact they're therein but
if some of it is real if some of it is
fake you state that in your in your
little or thing that you put out there
walls don't win with the 360 error you
got a hole that was a nice one actually
if you really look at it wasn't a real
win because the PlayStation caught up at
the end like I feel will catch up at the
end of this one but um no Mike come on
man two dudes fight it out and let the
loser walk with that l I welcome the
whole L until I PlayStation far come out
anything third party they will I think
you know this is a game they're like
like we saw it's time for that at the
beginning in the past is somewhat
unoptimized it's not 100% ready and they
jumped on me early and it you know they
were still worked and he didn't be done
on it you know what it is you know it
shout out your phone's ready to chat me
he made a good point
you know traditionally the humans they
make mistakes things happen you know I'm
saying Dave maliciously went out there
did you like really is one of those
things that I do like to do situation
happen because it shows that one they're
not above being checked and they never
be are above reproach so I like when
everybody gets questioned now because
people now you're going in on EA T going
in on bungee with destiny anything you
put in your game or any type of you know
comment or assessments you make this
they got to get checked you know I'm
saying but they got a whole less L you
know I mean it is what it is you know
the question I want to ask real quick to
go back to y'all let's just say they did
the files out
they're like D really big r34 big things
can have a legal leg to stand on
you think they could try to say what I
do think they could do is put these tiki
torches do the action the way the
developer argued it was like oh it's
really unfair that it would being called
lazy this and the other so the the way
they said it was inferred that that
digital foundry in the video said they
were lazy which they would never do so
it was it was the hate they were getting
and Twitter and everything from people
that were like hey you know something
Twitter messages like this is lazy
this is unacceptable this than the other
so he just woke up to all that hate and
he just pissed off that you know they
they misrepresented the game in that
fashion so I'm saying all this anger is
directed at them but but here's the
thing though this is where I want to
defend him because Charlotte alone
anchorman in the chat oh yeah I got the
collection I think that patch is coming
next week okay I hear what you're saying
Lauren come in he what you saying they
probably don't have a leg to stand on
legally right I get it but we have to
admit this right if your game was ripped
on digital foundry in this era do you
know how much damage that does to your
marketing cuz we all praise Microsoft
when they went to digital foundry and
said hey give them the Xbox 1x reveal
that's free marketing right so we were
like for the most part like you know it
was a good idea right it was good it was
smart so could you imagine like if
Microsoft gave it and they had incorrect
information
like oh it doesn't do this like that's a
lot of damage on a marketing level first
of all I didn't even know who 34 BT was
before all this you know so I think that
you know lawyers can do magic in the in
the law you know when it comes to law
and and get people paid but I think
they're just trying to get it I mean
they're getting Free Press free
attention so even if they don't you know
get anything done in the court of law I
think they still win right because
they're getting attention all over
social media they're getting attention
on this game I don't know man I I just I
think the the person that loot the
people that lose our digital foundry and
I think that what you were saying about
you know consumers being more educated
that needs to go for everything because
you can make a change in in all aspects
you know we saw with EA we're seeing it
with this you know these people gotta be
they put out there and that's that
should be the message that we focus on
right valid points just thought I
thought it was interesting this whole
fiasco no we probably gotta save I had
to 2018 thanks Dave but uh we were going
all but over I might say that for next
week
as far as um you know 2018 as far as
each platform what we want and stuff
like that but um anything else anyone
else got anything left for digital
frenzy before we wrap up and get to
posing other dudes out there Calvin got
a team he trying to get him together to
start doing these games man I'm telling
you now do not let it be a two horse
race where people can get channels to go
to to get the information on which
system is running this better which
system is running that better if
anything this this causes them to have
to tighten their game up because at the
moment he meant they mentioned VG Tech
in the article as saying oh they got
this part right and the people gonna
start going to VG Tech to see what kind
of how they can
yeah absolutely yeah I mean Fonzarelli
in the chat - I'm continuous I work it
off no no I just gotta tighten up now so
that it took that's a win-win for
everybody they're gonna have to tighten
up the Lord that the Lord's are feeling
the server today man it is appreciated
it's definitely show man because some
stuff about media bias I want to get it
to zero you have a big you have a mind
going so there's a lot of stuff about
you know that subway um we got an ILP
hold that we gotta get into it's a new
one of the week so basically it's in the
resolution era of gaming with 1080p vs
720p and now true 4k versus dynamic
checkerboarding 4k our gaming executives
wrong for engaging their fan base on
these subjects a yes it's a bad taste
and promote console war nonsense no
purely marketing stay out of your
feelings or see I don't care as long as
my sorrows with it those are the choices
please Rock the Vote at the IOP twitter
holes hardly goes up I gonna put it up
tomorrow so again we're gonna talk about
that Reza Shah tout the Lord so for
coming through you know say it at the
roundtable much appreciated man man it's
been a it's been a blast
I love you guys you guys are awesome I
mean that you guys signify what I like
in gaming just having a fun time and you
know just shootin the [ __ ] man that's
what it's all about right yes sir much
appreciate always a pleasure we love
what we saw we saw like your entire
almost except all Disney we had the
whole Luke Cesare do a podcast crew in
here we had a radio bro we had some
other people that I follow and they
follow me on Twitter so it's it's been a
party man the chats been lit props you
guys thank you so much thanks oh thanks
oh where could I find people find you
and also like what you got cooking up
like the people no get your plug on man
okay okay okay
saltiest podcast is moving what is it
back an hour it's gonna be 8 p.m.
Eastern instead of 9 p.m. Eastern it's
gonna be a lit it's gonna be awesome
tonight man we have the guest is gonna
be irrelevant native he was in the chat
he's an awesome guy Chad I like him yeah
okay he uh he's been doing debates when
it comes to religion in real life so
he's gonna he's both spoken he's a cool
dude I've been gaming with them
we made a good friendship punk kiddush
gaming is gonna be a permanent member we
had someone leave due to scheduling so
it's gonna be an awesome first episode
of 2018 we had to take a couple weeks
off for because you know it fell on
Christmas Eve and New Year's Eve but it
is going to be lit so stay tuned for
that and yeah moving forward I'm just
gonna be getting content out like I
always do but we're gonna be improving
upon that content because it's always a
constant learning process when it comes
to YouTube so I'm focusing on making my
videos better on the daily and then
we're gonna be doing game reviews and
you know maybe some playthroughs if I
can get that going I'm all I'm also on X
X power on Monday so stay tuned for that
and Lulu chess radios different I think
some people it's not focused on YouTube
like the live streams we do pre-recorded
stuff so you could catch that and it's
gonna be on all the podcasts
availabilities you know on-demand so
that's with J Fonz he's been in the chat
he's awesome and braaap and we got all
day digital there so yeah that was
long-winded but that's where you can
find me salt is gaming two words you can
find me on Twitter sorry the eye is a
one I love to talk to people on social
media so hit me up there yeah thanks for
having me on guys pleasure I love what
you're doing out here like I said we're
gonna make sure everyone hit that
subscribe button again really support
this guy just to see his rise his
passion for gaming and what he's doing
out there the sausage podcast likes
power Luke says rainy all our peeps and
it's just good stuff it's good to see
like-minded people and definitely
appreciate you gonna definitely have
your back you know that
your bills get these outraged I've been
lured to solve it can the find people
find you yeah everybody can find me on
Twitter Lord saw by Opie and on Xbox and
Playstation and BX sovereign enough big
shout-out to Lord salt man dad that was
for coming on and help him to start the
year off right lit like it's doorways so
if that was fantastic
no that would do some salt on it for the
new year
Lord King we could Bobby behind you sir
you can find me on Twitter Instagram
Facebook but I wanted to give a shout
out to Lord salty oh I met Lord salty in
the next podcast meaning that did the
next podcast my boy X bye you know it's
um yep
I love his energy his energy is not
overt is not submissive it's it's it's
in the pocket he plays it in the pocket
and his opinion is very strong without
being you know overbearing and and and
it's very the thoughts behind it comes
across very well and I couldn't wait you
know for today and I knew the podcast
was gonna go great
just because he was gonna be here so
thank you for coming through I do
appreciate you coming through at a great
time which then I have a great time with
you now guys we're gonna get this boxing
and all this stuff coming we got arrow
Spence
you ready get it on we should have some
more UFC this week I'll be on the top of
my game you know Chris Eyeborg had me
kind of messed up for May 2 and boxer so
he loves we wanted to get him on one of
the shows for that when we had out that
match goes down so alright guys you
already know and like I said earlier we
hate new gaming realness was spent on
IOP told you what you now what you
wanted to hit what you needed to hear
thanks again los ulti for coming through
everybody in chat man like you have no
idea is so appreciated you know just
that you guys missed us and just to see
the support man it really means a lot to
us and no we're not the biggest but I'm
growing and it really fell
good man just to see that people really
miss you let's talk gaming and having
fun and all that good stuff so yeah hit
the like I hit the subscribe make sure
you support the unit circle media all
the other outlets we got the multi-verse
on deck tomorrow morning and make sure
you check those guys out they got some
cool stuff going in there man it's good
to be back new year new day we gonna get
this thing pop and we got a lot of stuff
cooking for you so you guys have a good
one enjoy your Sunday and on that note
we are out peace